ich muss natürlich ein bisschen gucken
was jetzt die politik so von mir
verlangt das wird oft gesagt bio ist
gleich besser aber für mich ist das
nicht unbedingt so weil man auch
konventionell die tiere artgerecht
halten kann
hey ich bin kamen und ich nehme ich
hätte mit immer leben
ich finde angela merkel hat ihren job
eigentlich ganz gut gemacht aber ich
glaube so langsam könnte sie dann doch
mal abgelöst werden
ich war hier die gänse waren macht den
strom aus und ihr fangt ihr an die liste
nennt
ich habe mich dazu entschieden den hof
zu übernehmen und landwirtschaft zu
machen obwohl es nicht einfach ist man
übernimmt verantwortung
mit eigenen haus ziehen und auch
im ganzen land ein mann sechs in den
ganzen betrieb sorgt auch sehr gut mit 3
mein tag hat ungefähr elf zwei stunden
morgens anfangen ans aufhören und also
arbeitsspitzen sowie ernte oder sowas da
ist schon abends dann echt die luft raus
die können richtig weil so ganz schaffen
ob dafür ob das an meiner meine
ausbildung liegt oder aber auch die
beiden bin ich stolz sie können anpacken
die haben die im überblick also da bin
ich schon stolz drauf das kann man so
weiterlaufen
[Musik]
normalerweise ist es schwer heute dass
überhaupt ein verkünder im betrieb
weiter macht weil naja die die
aussichten viel zu arbeiten und wenig zu
verdienen sind richtig gut aber ich bin
ganz kurz darauf die beiden mädels
machen mann betrieb weiter
ja auch nicht gerade
wenig arbeit die mit körperlicher arbeit
auch verbunden ist
das ansehen der landwirt in der
bevölkerung das hat sich über die jahre
glaube ich sehr verändert früher nach
dem krieg allem landwirte hochgelobt und
hauptsache es kam es nur weil alle
hunger hatten jetzt leben wir in einer
überflussgesellschaft und alle haben
genug und satt und reichlich zu essen
und da kommt das thema immer mehr auf zu
wenig art gerecht und machen nicht genug
naturschutz da ist jetzt werde ich jetzt
gehen wir wieder offen aber die neue
wiese lassen
ich möchte eben dass sich das immerhin
stelle wirtschaft irgendwann verbessert
dass der konsument irgendwann merkt okay
sie sind doch angewiesen auf die
landwirte
versuche den betrieb so weiterzuführen
wie er jetzt ist ich muss natürlich ein
bisschen gucken was jetzt die politik so
von mir verlangt wir wollen unsere tiere
unsere schweinehaltung ein bisschen
umstellen das ist jetzt noch sehr
konventionell artgerechtere haltung also
aus dem klima stall mehr platz weniger
schweine vielleicht ein bisschen stroh
zum einstreuen das ist so mein ziel und
dann mal gucken was ich noch so ergibt
vielleicht kann ich ja die akr
wirtschaft nach umstellen oder was
anderes anbauen
[Musik]
ab und zu meinte das schmeckt natürlich
der nicht mehr so gut dass mutter
deswegen mache ich das alte futter und
auch das foto jetzt drin ist
und die erstrecken sich gerne mal
[Musik]
man sollte meinen langsam kennen weil
wir ja täglich sommer durchgehend aber
naja
da sieht soweit sauber aus
es wird oft gesagt bio ist gleich besser
aber für mich ist das nicht unbedingt so
weil man auch konventionell die tiere
artgerecht halten kann und auch im
konventionellen bereich wird
antibiotikum oder irgendwelche
medikamente auch nur eingesetzt wenn es
wirklich notwendig ist genau wie bei uns
menschen
egal ob alle fressen alles was wir
meinen
[Musik]
unsere arbeit machen moment solche
probleme schwer dass uns eben viel
vorgeworfen wird es wird gesagt wir
durch so viel wir verpassten umwelt und
es wird viel auf den landwirten
rumgehackt und dadurch entstehen immer
mehr verordnungen
[Musik]
man darf nichts und dokumentiert lassen
und in der tierhaltung ist es auch so
wenn du zum beispiel stahl gewaschen hat
musste aufschreiben wann habe ich den
gewaschen dann habe ich den tessin
verziert dann sind welche tiere raus
gekommen also auf wie auf jedem betrieb
ist jedes tier nachvollziehbaren obwohl
man eigentlich denkt okay wen
interessiert denn jetzt wenn ich den
schnell leer gemacht hat und wann ich
den sauber gemacht habe
[Musik]
ich finde landwirte sollten in
politische entscheidungen definitiv mit
eingezogen wäre einbezogen werden denn
die verordnungen die getroffen werden
betreffen den einzelnen landwirt und man
kann als praktischer dann wird deutlich
mehr dazu sagen als von leuten die nur
die theorie kennen irgendwelche
verordnungen aufstellen lassen
[Musik]
von der politik müsste sich insofern was
ändern dass das land wird von ihrer
arbeit leben können dass die bürokratie
zumindest ein bisschen abgeschafft wird
dass es nicht unbedingt noch schwerer
gemacht wird nun landwirtschaftlichen
betrieb zu führen oder den sogar auf bio
umzustellen weil das macht die
landwirtschaft nur noch unattraktiver
[Musik]
wenn man es gegen den supermarkt und für
die direktvermarktung an den kunden
entschieden da wir nicht so die mengen
haben die ein supermarkt wöchentlich
bräuchte und wir wollen eben das ganze
tier verwerten dass wir gut machen
können indem wir auch selber wurst
herstellen
wir haben die rezepte jemals
überleben können von a wie vor in den
metzgermeister
den wir kennen gelernt haben und er hat
uns das know-how beigebracht von daher
sind wir also quereinsteiger wie so
schön heißt aber man kann trotzdem
richtig gut was draus machen wenn man
mit leidenschaft dabei so wie wir dann
klappt das schon
[Musik]
es kommt nicht so häufig vor dass kunden
sagen dass wir jetzt zu teuer denn die
konnten die dänen das zu teuer ist sie
kommen auch erst gar nicht und dann sind
das auch meistens die dann im supermarkt
einkaufen und nicht auf dem verkaufen
woche macht
[Musik]
also wenn ich sehe wie billig dass
rindfleisch im supermarkt angeboten wird
da bin ich dann schon echt enttäuscht
und traurig darüber dass sowas überhaupt
gekauft wird denn ich weiß dass viel
weniger bei dem landwirt ankommt als
dass er eigentlich gearbeitet hat und
wie viel geld er eigentlich kriegen
müsste außerdem wird die verantwortung
eigentlich beim konsumenten denn es
zeigt sich dass trotzdem es bio oder
artgerechte haltung im supermarkt zu
kaufen ist das trotzdem das billige
angebots fleisch oder gemüse gekauft
wird
[Musik]
ob es zufrieden heute mama ja wir haben
auf jeden fall ein bisschen was verkauft
und wir fahren mit weniger zurück als
wir gekommen sind
das saatgut ja der aufwand der lohnt
sich dessen wir haben den zwischen dann
lerne ich hinterlegen kann man das schon
machen
[Musik]
sie sagt uns gekommen mehr als
490 handel 49 sekunden hatten wir heute
ist in ordnung
[Musik]
heute morgen geht es auf dem hochsitz
mal gucken was für sie sehen können
[Musik]
schon seitdem ich hier bin ist das bei
uns in der familie traktion mein opa war
jäger mein bruder meine schwester und
mein vater wir haben alle einen
jagdschein und die jagd wird bei uns wie
gesagt zur tradition deswegen liegt mir
das schon am herzen diese tradition
weiterzuführen und auch beim zu behalten
[Musik]
es gibt ein paar mehr junge jägerinnen
und es werden immer mehr ich habe ein
zwei freundinnen von dem ich sagen kann
das ist englisch können sind die auch
jäger sind aus der freundeskreis meiner
schwester sind auch viele jägerin ich
würde deshalb vielleicht bei uns im dorf
ist es schon
bekannt aber die jagd jetzt sowieso auch
bei buecher.de hat
[Musik]
also gerade das thema naturschutz ist
natürlich ein sehr sehr großes thema
gerade jetzt mit dem dichten bestand der
akku holz wurde und die ganze wälder die
wieder neu aufgeforstet werden die
werden vom rehwild sehr gerne wieder
zerstört das hat auch mit sehr viel geld
zu tun und es gibt eben keine
natürlichen feinde
daher ist es sehr wichtig das ist die
jagd dass man seine abschlüsse macht
aber auch also nicht nur wegen des
bestandes und der natur sondern auch
wegen der krankheit und den themen an
sich
[Musik]
jagd ist eben mehr als auch muss jetzt
gehen sie abschießen damit umzugehen
denn es ist ja immer diese atmosphäre
und die ruhe und das alles was man so
mitbekommen man kommt ein bisschen auch
vom alltag so runter weil man eben der
sitzt und wartet und nicht viel anderes
zu tun hat also es lohnt sich auf jeden
fall
ich würde mir von der neuen regierung
wünschen dass die bürokratie in der
landwirtschaft ein bisschen abgeschwächt
wird zum gewissen maß ist bestimmt
sinnvoll aber so wie es jetzt ist es ist
einfach zu viel und es wäre vielleicht
ein ziel für die zukunft dass die eu
mehr zusammen arbeitet auch im thema
landwirtschaft und das in der
landwirtschaft die gleichen richtlinien
und verordnungen und regeln gibt
wir nehmen noch mehr sehen wollt dann
guckt auch in der zdf mediathek vorbei
da gibt es weitere porträts